in the final seconds of the 2009 film
The Blind Side Leanne Tui played by
Sandra Bullock reflects on the murder of
a 21 year old black athlete in a local
housing project the young man had
dropped out of school fallen in with the
wrong wrong crowd and had died in a
gang-related shooting
that could have been my son Michael
Leanne says right before the credits
roll I suppose I have God to thank for
that
a decade later it's hard to imagine a
film from a major Studio ending that way
the film began with Leanne Tui seeing a
homeless teenager named Michael Orr
walking down the street in the cold she
and her husband Sean decided to take
care of the kid and finally after years
of sacrifice or goes to college and
eventually goes on to become a
successful NFL player in 2009 when
audiences weren't lobotomized by
procedurally generated Marvel slop that
plot line resonated and The Blind Side
made over 300 million dollars on a
relatively small budget Sandra Bullock
won an Oscar although she herself
admitted during filming that her acting
wasn't even that good Leon Tui used the
film success to help children find
foster homes on social media and outside
of a few whiny articles on NPR or The
Daily Beast people basically love the
movie
the media loved the movie for the most
part
in the years that followed the film's
release though the tone changed as
Barack Obama set race relations in this
country backwards by 50 years academics
who are the source of most bad ideas and
cynicism in the world for some reason
began obsessing over The Blind Side they
kept writing about it years after
everyone else had moved on in 2015 for
example a Clemson Professor wrote this
article in the journal studies in
popular culture here's the title racial
discourse in The Blind Side the
economics and ideology behind the white
savior formats
that same year the University of New
Mexico Professor authored a piece
entitled The White cinematic lens
decoding the racial messages in The
Blind Side
as the years progressed so did the
left's obsession with the Blind Side
their fixation continued after the Obama
years in 2019 a professor at Texas State
University somehow attempted to connect
Donald Trump with the Blind Side with a
piece entitled colorblind racism the
Trump effect and The Blind Side and if
you want to lose 50 IQ points you can
read the abstract online but I'm not
going to bother reading it to you that
same year 2019 the popular YouTube
channel Be Kind Rewind released this
video explaining that the movie has a
white savior problem watch
this movie could have included the black
families that United to support Michael
before he lived with the Deweys
full-time it could have been about
organizing pickup football games as a
kid with his friends fostering a Love of
the Game that he honed in high school
but John Lee Hancock chose not to do
that instead he canonizes a singular
white family and D platforms the
supportive black community that ore did
have that decision empowered Sandra
Bullock with ample opportunities to
demonstrate wit vulnerability
self-confidence and kindness in the
process to be the Spitfire of the
critics noticed in other words it gave
her an Oscar bait role that's what white
savior films do they shift focus and
blame they implicitly tell audiences
that white stories are more interesting
or worthy of your time than the stories
of people of color
that's all you got it the film should
have been about all the people who
didn't house or educate or care for
Michael Oher it should have been about
the kids who played basketball with him
I mean why like what kind of movie would
that even be what's the story there uh
well just because they're black and the
family that took care of Michael Oher is
white that's the level of analysis
all of these articles and videos and
plenty more examples I could have used
demonstrate that The Blind Side
triggered a deep underlying pathology
that tortures the supposedly
intellectual left
they simply can't tolerate the film's
message
to this day they just can't get over it
and they definitely can't allow any
other major Studio to make a film like
it I mean that's never going to happen
in the past few days predictably this
effort has entered a new somehow even
more demented and tragic stage Michael
Oher filed a legal complaint complaint
against the tuis as we talked about a
few days ago the media is promoting it
relentlessly they could not be more
thrilled by this development watch
we all remember the 2009 Sandra Bullock
movie The Blind Side the true story of
NFL star Michael Orr who was adopted out
of poverty by a wealthy family the new
court docks filed by orapine a far
different picture I was just enthralled
by her I I didn't think I could play her
it was just such a beautiful story
Sandra Bullock won an Oscar for
betraying Michael Oher's adoptive mother
Leanne Tui the southern mother of two
took in the six foot four then homeless
and traumatized teenager when no one
else would Michael was betrayed by
Quentin Aaron do you want to stay here
Michael
I don't want to go anyplace else but now
the former NFL star alleges Leanne and
her husband Sean never officially
adopted him but instead allegedly
deceived him into making them his
conservators just after his 18th
birthday an illegal petition filed today
in Tennessee Michael claims that tuis
use the conservatorship to make
themselves and their birth children
millions of dollars in royalties from
The Blind Side the toys haven't
responded to our request for comment
back when the movie came out Leanne told
us Michael was proud of the film I sent
him a letter yesterday I'd gotten from
someone Atlanta and I forwarded it to
him and I got back the sweetest text and
he said I'm really proud this is making
a difference and so he knows it is
well I'm glad we're past that I'm glad
we found a way to take this heartwarming
tale and it turned it into a problem it
said thank God
you certainly can't have a story like
you can't have a story especially if One
race of people helping another race of
people I can't you we can't have that we
can't allow it well it's clear that the
left is giving up their morals in any
Common Sense there's no better time than
to build a daily habit of prayer and
meditation building a habit of prayer
can help you cultivate an attitude of
gratitude focusing on what you're
thankful for can increase positive
emotions and improve overall well-being
Hollow is the number one Christian
Prayer app in the US it's helped me
maintain a daily prayer routine can help
you do the same download the app for
free at hello.com Matt Walsh you can set
prayer reminders track your progress
along the way not sure where to start
we'll check out father Mike schmitz's
Bible in a year podcast available on the
Hello app and and uh you can also pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim could easily
been some world-class athletes with
howlo you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using hello to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
ultimately we'll learn how we can now
become better individuals in spite of
today's broken World As We strive to
become more like Christ in our daily
lives through prayer fasting and giving
download Hello hello.com Matt Walsh you
get exclusive three months free that's
three months absolutely free at
hollow.com Matt Walsh
now the Crux of the legal complaint is
that the two he's tricked Michael Oher
into thinking that he was adopted when
in fact the two he simply had a
conservatorship over him allowing them
to take most of his money
so they're not good-hearted white people
helping out a black kid they are evil
white supremacist thieves that's the
idea
but before we get into uh the actual
complaint there's a couple of points
first of all
that report you just saw implies that
the two is defrauded or because they
wanted money and what they don't mention
is that the tuis are extraordinarily
wealthy
independently wealthy in fact they're
far wealthier than ore has ever been
even after his NFL career or expected to
believe that this family which is worth
well over 200 million dollars
schemed to rip off Michael Oher is that
plausible I mean right away it doesn't
pass the smell test as I said a few days
ago it sounds a lot like a washed up
athlete who burned through the cash he
made in the league and now he's looking
for a Payday and some relevance
and indeed ore's claim is especially
suspicious since according to the two
he's Orr has been shaking them down for
15 million dollars for a long time now
allegedly he filed this lawsuit only
after trying to get the quick cash from
a family he knows is Rich and which
still loves him
but there are more problems with this
complaint beyond the ones that I just
mentioned for for this acquisition to
make sense for one thing the twois would
have had to see this homeless teenager
walking on the side of the road
and say to themselves
this kid's gonna make us rich
his grades are terrible no college
program is interested in him his father
abandoned him his mother's a drug addict
but he's going to make us a lot of money
someday
and then there's going to be a movie
about him and we'll get royalties from
that
and then through all this as they raised
him and sent him to college or it would
be blissfully unaware of this dastardly
scheme for more than a decade
and then and then it hits him somehow
quoting from ore's legal complaint quote
the LIE of Michael's adoption is one
upon which co-conservators uh Leanne Tui
and Sean Tui have enriched themselves at
the expense of their award the underside
Michael or Michael Oher discovered this
lie to his Chagrin and embarrassment in
February of 2023 when he learned the
conservatorship to which he consented on
the basis that doing so would make him a
member of the Dewey family in fact
provided him with no familiar relations
with the tuis
so the claim is that Michael Oher
realized only in February of 2023 that
he hadn't been legally adopted it took
him until this year to figure that out
is that possible
well corporate media is certainly buying
it with no skepticism whatsoever
NBC wrote up the allegations without
applying any form of of scrutiny at all
MSNBC wants you to know that this is all
your fault to actually quote Orr's
lawsuit is an indictment of movie
audiences that over and over again lap
up stories about white people saving
some downtrodden black person
now you might listen to that quote from
the MSNBC article and wonder what
Universe MSNBC is living in in fact if
you read any MSNBC article you're going
to wonder that but especially this
because in this universe movies about
white people saving black people are
extremely rare
and at this point basically non-existent
I mean can you name the last one besides
The Blind Side
go ahead
what's the last major Hollywood film
where the good guy the protagonist is a
white person who is helping out a black
person
that's really none come immediately to
mind
now for its part the uh the guardian
brought out the big guns they report
that quote the blind side's white savior
tarot tale was always built on Shaky
Ground
according to the piece quote the movie
version of The Blind Side has come to
represent a low point for the white
savior Trope the unlikely story of the
rich white lady who turns a downtrodden
black teen Hulk into an improbable
Sunday Pro Jeffrey Montez De OCA the
founding director of the center for
critical study of sport at the
University of Colorado in Colorado
Springs took aim at the film's framing
of adoption as a signifying Act of
whiteness that obscures the social
relations of domination that not only
make charity possible but also create an
urban underclass in need of Charity in
our seminal Tome uh White fragility
Robin D'Angelo excoriates the film as
fundamentally and insidiously anti-black
what all these stories have in common
though is that they don't interrogate
the claims in Orr's lawsuit at all
they don't spend any time looking at it
the media is so giddy that The Blind
Side is under attack they don't care to
actually do any journalism they just
Trot out the usual fake experts to call
it racist as they've been doing for a
decade now Inside Edition even got in
touch with the actor who betrays Michael
Oher in the film to ask him whether
Sandra Bullock should surrender her
Oscar which is a question so
stupid that the actor should respond by
just laughing hysterically at it but
that's not exactly what happens watch
Michael Oher is now saying the Tui
family never adopted him as everyone
thought he claims in his lawsuit that
the twois tricks him into becoming his
conservators meaning they have control
over his money what is your reaction to
what he's alleging I wasn't expecting
that I I think a lot of people myself
included again had such high hopes for
the family and and that Union that we
fell they had put together Sandra
Bullock won an Oscar for playing Leanne
Tui but now some people on social media
are actually calling for Bullock to
return her Oscar can you tell me what
you think about this call by some for
Sandra Bullock to return her Oscar she
was an actress who did her part and was
recognized for it Michael Orr who went
on to become an NFL star also says he
resented how the movie made him appear
less intelligent I didn't know who
Michael was before The Blind Side it
wasn't my intention to make him look
that way and I'm sorry that he took it
that way lawyers for the family say they
are stunned by Orr's actions which they
say are designed to drum up publicity
for his new book The Tilly's treated him
like a son
they loved him they don't need his money
they didn't they never needed his money
Miss Tui sold his company for 220
million dollars
The Blindside movie grossed 309 million
dollars
got him at the end there right notice
this the snark at the end the movie
grossed over 300 million the anchor
notes implying that the two he somehow
received all that money or even a
significant amount of it
like if you if you're if someone writes
a book about you and that's turned into
a movie if you're the subject of the
movie you get a hundred percent of the
profits because that's the way it works
now in reality they received less than
three percent of the proceeds which is
nothing compared to the 200 million
dollars they sold their company for
so this is the level of reporting we're
seeing on this with one exception over
at the blaze Jason Whitlock decided not
to Simply rewrite ore's complaint to
push a narrative it's written some
fantastic articles on this topic you
should read and it motivated me to
personally go and read some of the many
pieces of documented evidence
contradicting Michael Oher's claims
these are pieces of evidence that every
major media Outlet is ignoring for
example here's what Orr himself wrote in
his own Memoir in 2012 quote since I was
already over the age of 18 and
considered an adult by the state of
Tennessee Sean and Leanne would be named
as my legal conservators they explained
to me that it means pretty much this
exact same thing as adoptive parents but
that the laws were just written in a way
that took my age into account honestly I
didn't care what it was called my mother
was going to be at the hearing to agree
that she supported the decision to have
the two He's listed as my next of kin
and legal conservators
so that was more than a decade ago
Michael Oher an adult in his mid-20s at
the time when the Memoir was published
clearly acknowledges the distinction
between being adopted and being a legal
Conservatory clearly acknowledges that
he was not adopted
he uses the term Conservatory several
times in the book
but we're told to believe that more than
10 years later he finally decided to
look into it and realized he had been
tricked we're supposed to believe that
he just realized some truth that he
himself had already publicly
acknowledged in a book he published over
10 years ago
so how was Michael Oher supposedly not
aware of this did he not read his own
memoir
did he not watch the movie The Blind
Side there's a scene in the film where
Leanne establishes legal guardianship
over Michael Oher there is no scene
where she says that she's legally
adopting him that claim was never made
by anyone ever
now to be clear I can't say for sure
who's right or wrong in this case so I
have my very strong suspicions I
wouldn't be surprised if all parties
concerned or at least partially in the
wrong to some extent that's usually how
these kinds of conflicts go and if the
media wants to tell us that the tuis
aren't really saviors I'd certainly
agree with that there's only one savior
his name isn't Tui but then again the
two e's to my knowledge have never
claimed to be saviors they also never
claim to be Saints or martyrs they did a
nice thing for a kid who needed help
that's a fact and that's all
does this conflict stem from the fact
that although the tuis became Orr's
Guardians and treated him like a son
they didn't attend to actually pass
their Fortune down to him because they
wanted to go to their actual kids
is Michael Oher upset that he's not now
today as a 37 year old man reaping the
financial benefits of being a blood
relation to the tuies
I mean these are purely speculations but
I think reasonable ones
but I don't know the key point is that
the media's complete lack of curiosity
on all of these obvious red flags tells
you everything you need to know about
the left's perspective on race
a decade ago only a handful of
insufferable Outlets complained about
the Blind Side and now all of Academia
and the major media Outlets are doing it
you know they're United to smear a
family that helped save the young black
teenager's life without any regard for
facts or contrary evidence they're just
running in and running with the
narrative
after eight years of Barack Obama and
all those BLM riots and George Floyd
funerals
we've arrived basically at this moral
guidance
let the black teenager on the side of
the road freeze to death don't help him
or you're a racist
well at least we now have some clarity
from the party of black lives matter
and from the corporate media
somehow a sports movie from 2009 has led
them all to admit what they really think
which is better to leave the black kid
languishing in the gutter than reach out
and help him
better to look the other way than be a
white savior
that's the message coming in loud and
clear
and I suspect that a lot of white people
who have watched this Michael or saga
play out
who I've seen everything that's happened
over the past decade or so
are going to take that message to heart
and respond accordingly
the next Michael Oher the next
disadvantaged black kid who needs a
helping hand
might not get it
you might end up suffering the faith
that or likely would have suffered had
the two he's not stepped in
that's apparently what the left wants
and now tragically that's what they'll
get
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts